I regret tremendously not spending all
my money on Google in 2001 to 2004 when
I rewound how I built my dad's business
it was because I was handed a full house
it was called Google day one five cents
a click my kak was 10 cents my LTV was
$8 I didn't understand you got your
prospective be happy don't you want to
be happy
[Music]
something's become very obvious to me
only in the last couple of weeks that
maybe I'll pontificate a little bit here
which is I think the biggest reason so
many people within the marketing
landscape do have disagreements with
some of my points of view is because I
really don't think of myself as a
marketer for say I no question think of
myself far more as a business operator
who happens to have a knack or an
intuition towards marketing which has
helped me throughout my career but
everything I believe in is predicated on
the final result of what everybody in
this room is trying to achieve I just
think that marketing and communications
is an incredible way to get there to put
away their thanks T right and so what is
for a lot of you that don't know my
career I was born in the former Soviet
Union I came to the US and my father
grew from being a stock boy to owning a
small liquor store in New Jersey and
when I joined that business I fell it
first I fell in love with wine and wine
collecting which was great because it's
always good if you like what you're
doing but I built my dad's business from
a three to a sixty million dollar
business very quickly in the late 90s
without any B C capital even without a
credit line when I think about how
remarkable that growth was it was
completely predicated on practicality
which is really my North Star today no
man you know if I had the luxury to sit
and have dinner or breakfast with you
one-on-one for four hours and we
actually talked about what you're trying
to achieve in your business so much of
what I believe in whether it's Facebook
or Instagram or content or you know text
messaging is starting to really
be fascinating to me because in the US
and many other markets for about a
decade
we haven't allowed marketing inside of
our text numbers and all of a sudden I'm
seeing if I'm willing to do that which
you can imagine is attractive for us
marketers and business people so I think
the biggest reason I'm you know
interesting and debating in the
marketing landscape is I'm not a product
or a son of Nielsen ratings or data
logics or brand lift studies or
impressions or drop you know if you knew
nothing about marketing and you were a
normal business person you wouldn't be
attractive to low CPMs you would be
attractive to high CPMs because it would
lead to what you're trying to achieve so
I sit in marketing meetings in from
major clients around the world I sit at
conferences events like this and people
pontificate on data in the middle that
has nothing to do with the end business
result that is my problem
that is why I'm an outlier that's why
I'm different I'm I'm not of the machine
I'm of the business result I'm not you
know it's really interesting by only
running businesses for myself my whole
life I only care about long-term
branding and marketing a lot of times
people think about digital as a short
term sales funnel I think of it as
reverse I think Facebook and Instagram
thank you so much for being a part of
this but I think that they're doing a
not a good job in expressing how much
branding is done in their channels
because the conversion is so obvious for
math and sales when I think about this
room whatever it may be the business
result that one's trying to achieve I
watch so many of your behaviors globally
in overspending for a list celebrities
in Hollywood that don't have the value
they used to in overspending in Qantas
transactional Google and Facebook
behavior where CAC and LTV are the
religion and branding is not i watch a
lot of things that if I bought your
business or if I ran it I wouldn't
believe in but everything in the system
everything that the marketing industry
has been built on for the last half
century values things that I just don't
think are mapping to reality I'm
um fresh eyes to this industry I've only
been in an environment where big
companies have been part of my life for
the last decade prior to that it was
only entrepreneurship in Silicon Valley
and so it's been it's been an amazing
journey for me the last half decade in
watching what what is put on a pedestal
in an environment when you don't see
every dollar spent where it goes to what
happens when you fall too deep and
they're just caring about the value of
every dollar in the short term it's you
know to be honest too for my DNA it's a
bizarro world you know an industry that
goes to the south of France to celebrate
itself on subjective creative and uses
those awards to justify hundreds of
millions of dollars and spend this
fascinating this you know and I think
the giggles and the giggles come from a
deep understanding of the truth you know
and so here we are in 2019 whether in
the UAE America Europe all over the
world you have you have a game of two
individuals you have people who are
spending money and it's not their
business and you have people that are
spending money and that's how they feed
their family and those two people the
way they spend their money and what they
believe in have never been more opposite
than today and that's what I'm
fascinated by the people that are
incentivized of the health of the
business in the short and long term
versus the people that are incentivized
on the KPIs within the machine that they
have to navigate through i deploy
empathy I used to judge a lot of people
in this room on paper a decade ago I
thought I was smarter I know I'm not
smarter I just know that I'm playing a
different game I'm running a marathon in
perpetuity I put out content to be
historically correct so I can trade on
reputation in a decade not on what pays
my bills in the short term so I have the
advantage of the framework that I've
stumbled into within this environment
but it doesn't make it any less true and
so a couple things that I would tell you
know if you leave with anything then the
one word I would leave with if you're in
here today is volume the the sheer
volume of content that is needed by the
businesses in this
is staggering it's staggering if you get
you're above the line creative agency to
interpret your TB and make a ton more
content for the internet if you have a
digital shop that there's a lot of
content if you do publishing deals where
Conde or Hearst or refinery or pure Wow
or giving you content if you build
internal capabilities for content if you
have all four of those things humming
you're still 90% short on how much
content you need in a 20-19 world if you
understand how the googles and Facebooks
and snapchats actually work if you if
you are a deep practitioner of the media
capabilities of 2019 across the biggest
platforms which oh by the way in this
region have so much attention it's
uncomfortable if you really understand
that you'll realize oh my god I need
20,000 8,000 unique pieces of content
for different psychographic demographic
individuals and as you all know even
Vayner which I'm trying to move in the
direction of being the disproportionate
leader in quality and quantity there's
no engine in the world right now that's
even remotely close to the needs that we
actually have so that to me is the big
one that to me is in the last six months
the thing that is absolutely synthesized
which is my god if you really did it
perfect you know and and you really
spent it every penny the way I did for
my father's business perfect you need
20,000 pieces of meaningful content for
a year
that's about 19900 more than most people
have and so that I think will be the
debate over the next half decade how do
you have quality content at scale to
take advantage of the grossly
underpriced media capabilities of the
youtubes the snapchats the Facebook's
and the instagrams
over the next half decade then consumer
behavior will change either to our hosts
hope the prices become appropriate like
they did a Google search or people's
attention will move on like it was on
MySpace
that I don't know I don't guess I only
trade on the day we live in what I know
is if you look at the sheer data of
what's happening in this region
typically this is global outside of
mainland China and Russia if you look at
the sheer actual consumption not a GRP
or an impression which is a potential
reach but actual reach if you just look
at YouTube Facebook Instagram and
snapchat this is the golden era to
market in this region and most people
are not taking advantage of it because
either a they've allocated dollars to
traditional places based on reports of
yesterday or B even if they are it's not
successful because they don't have
enough content to fill the pipes of the
media distribution that to me is what's
going on how much is made for them or
for yourselves
I think utility and entertainment can be
made for them I think that if you look
at a lot of the communications in this
room I'm sure if you were to self audit
you'd be surprised how much is
self-serving that's very hard you do
that by whoever runs the company sets
that tone every company's DNA is
predicated on the CEO whoever she or he
is they're gonna dictate that so she or
he or disproportionally egotistical
around subjective creative the whole
organization will go up that I think
that you know that's that's something
outside the pay grade of like marketing
that is just absolutely operational
throughout the entire world you know
what is being held up as a religion
internally as fascinating.i looking at
the you know knowing who's in this room
you're either math doubt or your art out
you know they're they're very few
organizations that have a 50/50 balance
you either have a DNA internally that
disproportionately wants celebrities
from Hollywood and wants a one-minute
video that feels good
or you're disproportionately Google and
emailed out for CAC and ltb and I'm
fascinated why most organizations
haven't found that 50/50 balance and
understanding how both matter
and then more importantly how do we
actually score within that right
creative scorecard is laughable it's
human subjectiveness or reports that are
so laughably outdated or finally awards
or finally three or four magazines that
say it's a good piece of creative like
the way we judge is meanwhile we live in
a world where you can put this creative
in a Facebook or YouTube environment and
you can get qualitative feedback at
scale and just listen to the customer
instead the problem is most people start
top down not bottom up so you overspend
so heavily on one video that you're at
the mercy of reporting or if so sir base
testing or all these things that are
just again if you don't know anything
about him like I did an eight years ago
when you actually study
you know first time I ever heard
award-winning work leads to business
results which was like a big debate I
heard in the advertising world I just
had some two people on my team in in
research and strategy find out where
that started it was funded by agencies
sounds right and so I think those are
the themes of today well I think
everybody here should take a very simple
stance like I did a long time ago which
is that the internet will eliminate the
middle-right if you if you actually
understand what the internet does in its
most basic form it eliminates anybody in
the middle that provides no value that's
the squeeze so for me I think everybody
in this room needs to think about a
couple things if the internet squeezes
the middle that's how it plays out
Airbnb makes so much sense to me if you
think about it it's just inventory that
exists that the internet connected to
parties to no different than uber no
different than everything else and so
listen if you're an airline you know
obviously somebody has to then own a
plane and that becomes a cog that's more
expensive than other
but you know rules have less costs
involved as we've seen play out and then
you start getting into experiences and
other variables
but you can't just rely on the utility
part of that you've got to layer it it's
kind of how I think about what's
happened with television
it's the reason I knew that commercials
were going to be in trouble it's not
that it's not that I'm predicting it's
every day that you see Netflix and
YouTube consumption numbers go up that's
a problem for a network television and
then you just live in common sense like
consuming a commercial during a
television program is a very wild rarity
in 2019 when we all have mobile devices
I always laugh when people in the USA
but sports commercials are good
meanwhile the data is very black and
white the biggest spike on social media
is during the commercials of major
sporting events because everybody wants
to talk about LeBron or Messi or Tom
Brady did right and so you know it just
feels like one big game of inside
baseball where there's a lot of
financial incentives to hold up a facade
that no longer exists and unfortunately
for the biggest brands in the world the
executives making the financial
decisions are not incentivized to do the
right thing they're incentivized to
follow the scoring that's been created
internally that's on the CEOs head if
you know it's funny a lot of people razz
on me for my absolute statements but I
think of marketing like poker if you
have the best hand you go in I'm a boy
and I say a boy because this is what I
was a kid when this happened I am
unbelievably regret tremendously not
spending all my money on Google in 2001
to 2004 when I rewound how I built my
dad's business it was because I was
handed a full house it was called Google
day one five cents a click my CAC was 10
cents my LTV was $8 I didn't understand
because I didn't know I didn't have
experience yet I didn't know how to
quantify it it seemed normal to me I was
digitally native this seemed like it
made sense why wouldn't everybody do
this and then it went away and then two
thousand seven eight nine happened so
for me we're sitting in that moment
right now
Instagram story ads are so grossly
underpriced it's almost uncomfortable
I've hi I'm running actually this is
amazing mihari Union where yeah you know
this in four minutes in four minutes in
five days my follow COUNTA my Gary the
Arabic page went from nine hundred
people to thirty thousand seven hundred
people to thirty thousand because we
found a single piece of content that I
converted into Arabic from a piece of
content that is achieving 1.9 cent
follows on Instagram if you understand
how like the friction to get somebody to
follow you based on an impression
think about how inexpensive I'm getting
in front of every every Arabic speaking
person that is on Instagram to get one
point nine cent follows so when I found
out on a $200 spend that that was
working I just poured all my money into
it and I the way I'm gonna pour all my
money into it in perpetuity because I
want to extract the underpriced nature
of the media and I figured out how to
create the volume of content that broke
through to eventually get me a 1.9 said
follow because we've gotten on our xxx
piece of content we got there not on our
first people are running what making one
video and then putting it on YouTube and
Facebook and then saying is it work or
not we're not producing creatively
natively contextually to the platforms
that we're advertising on we're using
television mentality for the internet
it's just it's it's remarkably wrong and
and not even Vayner and let alone all
the traditional agencies are not in a
position to create the work needed for
the realities of the marketplace
you mentioned Instagram and obviously
there's a shift towards video talk us
through creating great content for that
and also in an increasingly mobile world
can you build a brand involve all along
of course you can because you can build
a brand on attention and the sheer
amount of attention on mobile is
extraordinary as a matter of fact why
would you know to me like when I look at
outdoor and I like outdoor there was a
nice little digital outdoor of me
speaking today I get excited about that
I like outdoor but I don't like outdoor
pricing in a world where while I saw my
little outdoor piece I looked around the
cars on the way here and every single
person not driving was looking at their
phone um even the drivers to your point
I'm a very simple guy tell me where the
attention is tell me what the cost is
associated with it do I think that's
right can I then create creative to fill
it at a low enough cost that I can test
7 10 15 this is not a bee testing this
is a to quadruple Z testing so for me
it's about producing quality content at
a low enough cost quality being
contextual and empathetic not high
production let me say that very slow cuz
it's super important quality being
contextual to the distribution and being
empathetic you have to know how to
overlay a sticker or animated Jeff on an
Instagram story to get people's
attention because that's native to that
platform not doing matching luggage of
your TVC for a short form 15-second
video for youtube that's what big
companies do
they start with television you've
already lost so you make a TBC or a
brand campaign and then you ask somebody
whether it's that agency or somebody
else or internally to cut it down for
Facebook and Instagram and YouTube
you're already in trouble for a couple
reasons
by nature brand campaigns and television
are Vennela because you're trying to
reach everybody with the reach of that
campaign if you start from the bottom
you can go after expats from the UK
versus expats from the US as you can
imagine if you know that that's who
you're gonna reach your message is gonna
be slightly different I'm filming right
now everywhere I go me and I rock like
I'm standing outside with these
beautiful views we're here a little
early and I'm saying hey snapchat find
out why I'm here at the UAE
I'm literally filming for the
distribution just by saying what's up
Facebook as my opening line
disproportionately increases the share
ability and earned media because I made
the creative native to the distribution
I didn't make one video that's gonna be
super glossy and then try to use
everything everybody views these
channels as distribution I view them as
contextual creative platforms I'm not
trying to get reach that isn't achieved
because I didn't make content for it
everybody's playing in a GRP and reach
world without having a common sense
layer over it of are you actually
getting that reach and then number two
does your content speak to that reach we
didn't have that with television but now
I can I can attack the 7 million people
in this market in 31 cohorts that matter
men and women are different 18 year-olds
are different than 40 tinier holes
making a million dollars a year is
different than making $40,000 a year we
do not take that into account and
creative because creative costs are too
high the machines for creative aren't
built for scale that is the rub in our
industry the media people know this when
I announced our framework that leads off
of what I'm talking about in September
where I started my company meeting with
I'm gonna put us out of business before
somebody else does it was the media
people that most like this creative
strategy the creative people like to
hold
to the political power of making a
subjective call not letting the market
its reactions quant and qual dictate
creative adjustment so it's a very very
interesting time right now we have way
too many conversations in the ad world
about the media side of things we are
not having the proper conversation of
the subconscious bias against the wrong
creative process for this room
[Music]
[Music]